ANDREW: We've got
a special guest
with us today,
Jennifer Pharr Davis.
She's logged over 12,000 miles
on six different continents,
including trails like
Pacific Crest Trail, Colorado
Trail, the Appalachian Trail.
She has a new book,
"Called Again,"
which chronicles her journey of
47 miles per day over 46 days.
And she's been featured
on the "New York Times,"
"Washington Post,"
"Talk of the Nation,"
"Daily Beast"--
the list goes on.
She's agreed to come here
and give a talk to us today,
and I'm very
excited to have her.
So please help me welcome
Jennifer Pharr Davis.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNIFER DAVIS: It's
always fun to share
some of my hiking stories.
And like Andrew said,
I've been able to hike
all over the world on
six different continents.
I have not been to
Antarctica, because I'm
a wimp in cold weather,
which we talked about.
But of all the places where I
have hiked and I have traveled,
the one trail that
means the most to me,
and the trail that has
changed my life the most,
is the Appalachian Trail.
And where I come from
in North Carolina,
we call it the
"Appa-lah-chin" Trail.
You may have heard of the
"Appa-lay-shin" Trail, right?
Well, that's not correct,
just so you know.
It's the "Appa-lah-chin" Trail.
Or at least we can
all agree on the AT.
And I've done the entire 2,185
mile AT three separate times.
And it was the most
recent time in 2011
where, with my husband's
help, and a whole lot of help
from friends, and family,
and hikers, and runners,
we set the overall record.
So for 46 straight days I
averaged 47 miles a day.
And that's crazy,
exactly, right?
Someone said it.
Yes, we can all agree
that that's crazy.
But hopefully, we can
also agree that a journey
of any distance or
any speed is always
going to start
with a single step.
Yes?
And my first step
into the wilderness
didn't take place until
I was 21 years old.
And that is so sad.
It is.
I grew up in a beautiful area.
But nowadays, with
school being so
demanding, and extracurriculars
taking up so much time,
unless your family's really
focused on going outdoors,
you're not going to spend a
whole lot of time in nature.
So I graduated from college,
and I didn't know anything
about the wilderness.
And that really bothered me.
And I felt like because
I didn't know much
about the natural world, I
really didn't know myself.
So I wanted to take some
time to try and fix that.
And growing up in
North Carolina,
I'd heard about the
Appalachian Trail.
I had never set
foot on it before.
In fact, I'd only
spent two nights
in the woods my entire life.
But the good news is, at age
21, that doesn't matter, right?
Inexperience never seems
to matter to 21 year old.
And I decided that I was
going to get out and do
that entire trail by myself.
So I started on my own, with my
brother's old Boy Scout gear,
in Georgia.
And my goal was to walk
all the way up to Maine.
And that first journey,
I was out there
for five full months, which
is very standard when you're
trying to hike the entire trail.
But at the time, it was
the five hardest months
I had ever known.
And even though it was 10 years
ago, I'll still today say,
it was also the five best
months of my entire life.
Because the trail
completely changed me.
And I needed that.
I liked the woman at
the end a heck of a lot
more than the girl who started.
And I could spend
all day telling you
about that first journey.
It was so foundational.
I could tell you
lessons I learned,
describe folks I met along
the way-- because, trust me,
there's some characters.
But you guys are at work.
You don't have all day.
We got to get you back and
being productive and solving
all the Google problems.
And so I'm going
to try to sum up
that journey and
that transformation
by reading a short passage
from my first book.
And this book chronicles
my initial journey
down the Appalachian Trail.
And it's got a
really strange name.
It's called "Becoming Odyssa."
Half the people read
the book, and they still
can't pronounce the title.
But just so you know,
Odyssa is my trail name.
And it's really
common when you go
and you hike these long paths
that, while you're out there,
you take a nickname that
hikers call a trail name.
I know we have hikers in here.
Do we have any trail names?
Are you willing to share?
AUDIENCE: Doc.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Doc.
Did you take that, or was
someone else-- gave it to you?
AUDIENCE: It was
kind of given to me.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Kind
of given to you.
Well, that's the
point I'm going for.
Because hikers love to
try and give other hikers
their trail name.
In my first week out there--
by the way, if you can't tell,
I am 6 feet tall.
And I've been this height
since eighth grade.
And my first week on the
trail, I got suggestions
like Sasquatch, Amazon,
and Stretch, yeah.
And all of a sudden, all those
old wounds from middle school
were just ripped open.
And I don't want any of those.
But then I was being a dork
and comparing the trail
to Homer's "Odyssey."
And another hiker said,
well, what about Odysseus?
And I liked that.
But I was proud to
be a woman out there.
Because there weren't
that many, especially
hiking by themselves.
So I wanted a
feminine trail name.
And we changed
Odysseus to Odyssa.
And I've been Odyssa ever since.
So here's a passage
from the last full day
of Odyssa's first journey.
"When people had asked why I
wanted to hike the Appalachian
Trail, one of the
answers I had given
was that I wanted time to think
about where I wanted to live
and what I wanted
to do for a living.
And the trail would give me
plenty of time to do that.
But now that I was at the
end, I didn't feel any closer
to knowing those answers
than when I started.
The only thing I
felt more certain
of at the end of this
journey was myself.
I was no longer
defined by my resume,
and I didn't give
answers based on what
I thought other
people wanted to hear.
For the first time in my
life, I knew who I was,
and I was OK with who I was.
At the end of this journey,
I knew that something deep
within me connected with
nature, and with hard work,
and with simplicity.
I also learned that I was
both stubborn and tough--
a lot tougher than I
thought I was, especially
when I let other people
help me along the way."
Now, when it was all said
and done, I got off trail,
and I got a job.
I mean, much to my mother's
relief, I got a job.
And it was a good job.
I was working with fun people,
living in a great place.
And I think everything said,
I should have been happy.
I should have been content.
But then the weeks
started to pass.
And the months started to pass.
And all I could think
about was the trail.
And I missed it.
I missed moving through nature.
My job was great, but
it was a desk job.
And I sat there for
eight hours a day.
And while I sat there,
I longed for the friends
I had made on the trail.
It was the first
environment I had
been a part of where the people
who were the closest to me
were extremely
different from me.
That made life really fun
and really interesting.
But surprisingly-- and I'm
going to say "surprisingly,"
because when I started, I
was your typical 21 year old.
And I was leaving behind
my friends, and my family,
and my computer, and TV.
And I was terrified
that, at times, I
would be really bored
and really lonely.
But then when it
was over, I longed
for the silence and the
solitude that I had discovered,
as much as I longed
for my friends.
But the thing I missed most
of all sounds really strange.
Because I missed how
beautiful I felt on the trail.
And I promise you, when I
was out there, I was filthy,
I mean covered in dirt.
We won't even talk
about the smell.
Because I don't think you
can put it into words.
And it's East Coast
smell, which by the way
is way worse than
West Coast smell.
Plus, there were
scrapes, bug bites,
bruises all over my body.
But here's the thing.
For five months, I
didn't have a mirror.
And I don't know if
this is funny or sad,
but the other week, I
went into a middle school.
And I literally had
to explain that this
was before the day of the
selfie, like I wasn't taking
digital pictures of
myself the entire way.
Plus, I didn't have billboards,
magazines, or commercials
telling me what I
should look like.
So I started to see myself
through my interactions
with other hikers.
And if I made
someone else smile,
that made me feel pretty.
Also, growing up, I
had always thought
that nature was beautiful.
But I had never seen
myself as a part of nature,
and a part of all that beauty,
until I walked the trail.
And finally, after
hiking through 14
states-- which I love saying
that on the west coast.
Because it makes it
sound so far, so long.
But after hiking through
14 states, at that point,
I based my self worth a whole
lot less on how I looked,
and a whole lot more
on what I could do.
And that's the
gift of the trail.
It makes you realize you can
do so much more than you once
thought was possible.
It exposes you to new things,
new horizons, new trails.
And I decided that
I really wanted
to do more, on
and off the trail,
more than I once
thought was possible.
So as time passed, I started
saving up money from work.
I started saving up
time away from work.
And I started to plan
another big hike.
And one of the great
things about being a hiker
is that there are
trails everywhere,
I mean all over the
US, all over the world.
And in my opinion, hiking is
one of the most affordable,
accessible, and
best ways to travel.
So I actually want
to take a minute
and share some of my
favorite hiking pictures
from different trails around
the world with you all.
And as the pictures
scroll through,
I'll try to tell you
where they were taken.
So we'll start our journey in
Africa at Mount Kilimanjaro.
[MUSIC ALATHEA, "COME HOME TO
ME"]
This is on the 600
mile Bibbulmun Track.
You see that big lizard.
The southwest
corner of Australia,
so just beneath Perth--
yeah, big spiders.
And here we go to Peru.
This is in Cotahuasi Canyon.
And that hurt.
That hurt a lot.
This is actually one of the
deepest canyons in the world.
And there are no
official trails.
There's just all these
old trading routes
that people still use.
So we were able to
navigate the entire canyon.
The next pictures come
from the Inca Trail
to Machu Picchu, which I know
some of you have been on.
And this is a trail
you all should all
check out at some point.
This is the Pacific Crest
Trail, runs about 2,700 mile
all the way through California,
Oregon, and Washington.
These pictures are not in order.
So this is Washington.
This is in the High Sierras.
That's a marmot friend.
That's Crater Lake in Oregon.
That's back up in Washington.
And those goats
can be mean, too.
They can be.
And all the rest
of the pictures are
going to come from
different parts of Europe.
This is in the Alps.
That's Mont Blanc
in the background.
This is in Iceland.
These next few pictures are
from a 50 mile trail in Iceland.
But there's more
diversity in that
50 miles than maybe the
entire Appalachian Trail.
And the last few shots are
from the United Kingdom.
This is from the coast of Wales.
And then there's some
shots from Scotland.
That was a monument at the
end of the West Highland
Way in Scotland.
And I always thought, that's
the perfect way to end a hike,
have that statue.
So hopefully, you guys
enjoyed those pictures.
Be glad that I did not sing.
That would not be a
pleasurable experience.
But the point of
showing those images
is just that the trail-- I mean,
I'm not a good photographer.
I'm not.
But the trail can take you
to these incredible places.
They're just so stunning,
so mind blowing.
And by the time-- for several
years, I just worked to hike,
and worked to hike,
and worked to hike.
But by the time I was 25, I
had admitted I had a problem.
And I said this recently,
and someone yelled back,
and 12 steps just
wasn't going to fix it.
And I was like, that's right.
I was a hiker.
I was.
All my time, all my money,
it was going to the trail.
So at that point, I
actually quit my day job
to start my own hiking company.
Because what I really
wanted to do was
get other people outside.
And I thought I could do it
through writing, and speaking,
and guiding on the trail.
But I still wanted to hike
a little on my own, too.
And I was in the
very beginning phases
of planning for
my next trip when,
all of a sudden,
something happened
that I thought might
ruin everything.
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: Ankle?
JENNIFER DAVIS: Ankle?
That is such a
sweet, naive guess.
No, I fell in love-- way
worse than twisting an ankle.
I fell in love.
I got engaged.
And I was convinced that
at the time in my life
when I was ready
to be married, I
would need to be ready to settle
down, or at least just slow
down.
But I was really fortunate
to meet this great guy who
loves me for me, which
is the crazy hiker.
And he's extremely supportive.
But maybe most
important of all, I
ended up marrying a
fellow who, at the time,
was a public school teacher.
So what does that mean?
AUDIENCE: Summer vacation.
JENNIFER DAVIS: That's right.
This could work, right?
And truthfully, I
had always wanted
to have adventures
with someone else.
I had gone on my own, but I'd
always wanted to share it.
And I told Brew--
that's my husband.
I told him, on our
very first date,
that I wanted to hike the
entire Appalachian Trail again.
So he knew what he
was getting into.
But as much as he loved me,
even after we were engaged,
he still did not want
to hike 2,185 miles
with me-- imagine that.
So we started to talk
about how I could hike,
but how we could also
spend time together.
And we came up with the idea
of doing a supported hike.
Now, a supported hike is
going to take a long trail
like the AT and basically turn
it into a series of day hikes.
Because now, instead of carry
my big heavy pack with tent,
sleeping bag, several days worth
of the food, all I had to carry
was a day pack
with just the items
I needed to reach the
next road crossing.
Because at every road crossing,
there would be my husband.
And what else would be there?
AUDIENCE: Food.
JENNIFER DAVIS:
Food, that's right.
Food, gear, supplies,
fresh socks-- fresh socks
are like the best thing
ever when you're a hiker.
They are.
So I could get
whatever I wanted,
but just what I needed
to reach the next road.
And as soon as we decided
that we would complete
the trail in that
manner, and knowing we
wanted to do it in
the summer months
when we could be together,
I decided that I also
wanted to try and establish a
women's record on the trail.
Because as long as I had
heard about supported hikes,
not all of them,
but a number of them
had been in regards
to records, people
trying to go very quickly.
But every record
I had ever heard
of on the Appalachian Trail,
not just speed-- oldest hiker.
By the way, do you want to
guess how old the oldest
hiker to do it all at once was?
AUDIENCE: 90.
JENNIFER DAVIS: 83, 83.
Youngest hiker?
AUDIENCE: 13.
AUDIENCE: Five.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Five.
The person who had
done it the most times,
which is 17 times--
that's over 35,000 miles.
All those records, all
those marks-- several folks
who had hiked the trail legally
blind-- they were all men.
All of them, every single
record, every single mark,
belonged to a man.
And I'm all about
some girl power.
So I thought, there should
be a women's record, too.
And truthfully,
there wasn't one.
So I figured if we were smart,
and if I stayed healthy,
we'd probably
accomplish that goal.
And it was back on June 8, 2008
when Brew and I got married.
And it was lovely.
But then just 12 days later,
we started the trail--
12 days later.
And once again, I can
spend all day telling you
about this one journey.
And I won't.
But I will say, if
you ever really want
to work on
communication-- I mean,
that might be a good
team building exercise,
to do a supported hike
for a couple days.
Because it forces
you to communicate.
And after 57 days of working
together, communicating, being
a team, we got to the end.
And we accomplished our goal.
When we arrived, we
established a women's record.
And along the way, I
averaged 38 miles a day.
38 miles a day, that's
not too shabby, right?
I mean, it was hard.
And it was challenging.
But I was surprised at
how much I loved it.
I loved it.
And now, when I look
back to that summer,
sometimes I feel like, well,
sure, I should have loved it.
Because there was, a
newlywed on cloud nine out
on my favorite trail
getting to do exactly what I
loved to do all day, every day.
And meanwhile, the man who
I loved more than anyone
was running all of my
errands, every single one.
But when we got to
the end, Brew and I
hiked up the last
mountain together.
And on the summit, there's a
plaque that represents the end.
So we went up to it.
And we both put our hands on it.
And as soon as we did,
I turned to my husband
just grinning from ear to ear.
And then he turned
to me, and he said,
we are never doing that again.
And he meant it.
But there was one
very small problem.
And that was we hiked off that
mountain to get to our car
and go home.
But as we descended
down the trail,
I knew that I could
have kept going.
I knew I still had something
left, something substantial.
And now, I also
realized that when
you're trying to set a
record on a very long trail,
it's not about speed,
or strength, or gender.
What do you think
it's all about?
You guys tell me.
What do you think
it's all about?
You can point, if you
don't want to talk.
Here, here, here, right?
Support-- someone has to
help you along the way.
There's a lot of factors.
But I was thinking
through those factors.
And now there was this small
voice inside me that said,
I might have what it would
take to set the overall record.
But I took that voice,
and I just [SWOOSH]
buried it down deep.
And I thought it would
probably go away.
And the next two
summers, Brew and I
agreed to hike much
shorter trails.
Granted, when I say
shorter, I am still
talking about 500 miles.
So they were decent
trails, but shorter.
We hiked at a slower
pace, side by side.
And even Brew would tell
you that we had so much fun.
We went out-- there's
a trail in Colorado
from Denver to Durango.
So we did that together,
and it was awesome.
And then the following summer,
we went over to Europe.
And there are foot paths
everywhere in Europe.
And we just had this
incredible time.
But meanwhile, what do you think
happened to the small voice?
Did it go away?
No, use your hands again.
Got bigger, got stronger,
and it got to the point
where I knew there
were only two options.
Either we would go back and try,
at least try, for the record.
Or else I would
always look back,
and I would always wonder
what might have been.
And I didn't want to do that.
So I sat down with Brew, and
we had a long conversation.
And I was shameless.
I used every bribe,
every bargaining chip
I could think of, which included
football game tickets, really
good craft beer, and
also future offspring.
I figured if I was going
to carry his stuff for nine
months, then he should carry
mine a little bit more.
And it worked.
He agreed to help
me one more time.
So in the summer of
2011, we went back
to the Appalachian Trail
for the third time.
Do we have any East
Coasters in here?
OK, I'll ask the question.
We decided we wanted a start
in Maine, not down in Georgia.
Why?
AUDIENCE: The heat.
AUDIENCE: Weather.
BREW DAVIS: Mosquitoes.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Weather?
We actually got the
worst of the bugs.
We traded the maximum
amount of daylight
for the worst of the bugs.
But weather, crowds-- wanting to
hike home, that was part of it.
However, the primary reason
we wanted to start up in Maine
is because Maine and New
Hampshire are the toughest
two states on the entire path.
Most of the time,
hiking up there
is not just walking
with your feet.
It's literally
scrambling up mountains,
or sort of sliding down them.
And if you're going to get
knocked off because of weather,
it's probably going to happen
up in Maine or New Hampshire.
So we thought,
well, let's just get
through that in the beginning.
So we started up in
Maine in mid-June.
And for the first
few days, everything
went about how we
thought it would.
Then on day five,
I was going up one
those steep mounts in Maine.
And on my way to the summit,
I noticed a sharp pain
that was developing
in my right leg
in between my knee and my ankle.
And by the time I
got up the ridge,
I was in so much discomfort
that all I could do
was limp down the trail.
And I kept limping until
the exact same pain that
was in my right leg
developed in my left leg.
By the end of the afternoon,
I had full blown shin splints.
And I can usually
look out, and I
can tell exactly who's
had shin splints.
Because I'll say the word,
and folks will be grimace
if they've had
them, just grimace
like it's the worst thing ever.
Because it's the
worst thing ever.
It really is.
And if you've had
shin splints, then you
know walking is very difficult.
Going uphill is excruciating.
But going downhill
is unbearable.
There were times on my descent
where I would plant my foot,
and my leg would just buckle
beneath me because of the pain,
and I collapsed
down to the trail.
But I was convinced
that my injury
had been caused by
the high mileage
days on the rocks in Maine.
I trained really hard,
but I trained down south
where we have a lot
of nice dirt trails.
And up in Maine
and New Hampshire,
they have a lot of exposed,
unforgiving granite.
However, if I can just make it
to Vermont-- Vermont's trail
name, its nickname,
is actually Vermud.
It is.
It's the one state
where you take a step,
and you lift your
foot, and the shoe
is no longer attached to it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's shoe sucking mud.
It's sloppy.
And it's messy.
But it's soft.
And I thought it
might be soft enough
to where my legs
could start to heal.
So that was my goal--
get to Vermont.
And all I had to do was
hike through New Hampshire
to make it there.
Exactly.
And even getting
into New Hampshire,
I was in so much pain
that almost every time I
got to the top of the mountain,
I would actually turn around
and then hike or scramble
downhill backwards.
And you see a lot of hikers
on the Appalachian Trail.
And no one once stopped and
asked me, hey, aren't you
that girl who's trying
to set the record?
No, but at that
point on the trail,
someone literally
stopped and asked
if I was lost or confused.
They thought I was backtracking,
because I was hiking backwards.
Yeah, but like so
many times in life--
and I think especially
with technology--
like so many times
in life, by being
willing to take a
few steps backwards,
I was able to keep
going forward.
And I got to New Hampshire.
And if there's one state on the
entire trail where I wake up
and I just pray for good
weather, it's New Hampshire.
When I arrived, I had 24
hours of decent weather.
Then I started up the
slopes of Mount Washington.
And Mount Washington
is not only one
of the highest
mountains on the trail--
and I'm not going to
tell you how high.
Because you West
Coasters will poo poo it.
But it's high.
And at one point, it had the
highest recorded wind speed
of any place on the planet.
It's notorious for its
wind and its bad weather.
And sure enough, as soon
as I got above tree line,
wind picked up.
We're talking the type of
wind that can knock you over.
And then the clouds rolled in.
And then on top of that,
the rain started to fall.
And out of all the
trails I've walked,
the Appalachian
Trail, relatively,
is the most well marked.
It's very difficult
to get lost on the AT.
Until you're above tree line,
and the next trail marker
is 40 yards away, and
you can't see 10 feet
in front of your face.
Then it becomes very
easy to get lost.
And I got off trail.
It took several hours
and several miles for me
to re-correct.
And even when I got
back to the right path,
it was such slow going.
Because all those rocks
were slick, wet rocks.
And I was slipping.
I was falling.
But I kept telling myself
that, at some point,
it would have to change.
It couldn't stay
like that forever.
And it finally changed after a
day and half of torrential rain
when I got up to
another high ridge.
And there, the
last week of June,
I was no longer
in the rainstorm.
Because now I was in the
middle of a sleet storm.
And I thought I was prepared.
I had great gear.
But I don't care what type
of Gore-Tex you're wearing.
After a day and half straight
of pounding rain, water gets in,
or sweat does not get out.
So I was up there
soaking wet, shivering.
I was starving.
And yes, I always have to
explain, I did have extra food.
But again, at some point,
you lose A, the dexterity,
or B, the desire, to open
another frozen Clif Bar
and just lick it.
That is not much fun.
So I was up there.
And I was in bad shape.
And I wanted to do
anything to take
my mind off the conditions.
And I mentioned earlier
that when I sing,
I have a horrible voice.
But when things go
really bad on the trail,
I'll start to sing to help
take my mind off of it.
And I decided to belt out
one of my favorite tunes
up on the ridge.
But from the very
beginning I was just
s-s-slurring the s-s-song.
And I was [STAMMERING]
mumbling all the words.
And, oh yeah, I was tripping
like every five or six steps.
So finally, I acknowledged
what, deep down, I already knew.
I was moderately hypothermic.
And it was becoming a
lot worse very quickly.
By the time I got to the base
of the mountain, I was so cold
and I was so stiff that I
could barely been my joints.
I remember, because there
were all these rocks steps,
and I kept feeling
like I could not
bend my knee to get
to the next one.
But Brew-- we have
not communicated.
He assumed, my
husband assumed, there
had been really nasty weather.
And so he hiked in
as far as he could.
And he set up our tent.
And as soon as I saw
the tent, I got inside.
Now, I was so rigid, I
couldn't even undress myself.
He had to help me out
of cold, wet clothes
into two sleeping bags.
And for the next 30 minutes, I
lay there and I just shivered.
But when I finally started to
relax just a little bit, what
do you think I
wanted to do next?
AUDIENCE: Get back up.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Get up, yeah,
wait, I heard a lot of things.
They're all correct, but the
first thing I wanted to do
was eat.
And food is wonderful
medicine for hypothermia.
It warms you from
the inside out.
And in the next 20 minutes, I
consumed over 3,000 calories.
Yeah, yeah, and I
know that for a fact,
because Brew took some
type of sick pleasure
in actually counting, keeping
a running tally of all
the calories that I was eating
on every single wrapper.
So at that point, I felt
a little bit better.
And I wanted to
try to keep hiking.
And Brew packed in the tent.
He brought the food.
He even remembered
extra clothes.
So I was able to put on a warm
fleece and a dry rain jacket.
But as I was getting
dressed, I realized
there was not an
extra pair of pants.
So I turned to the
corner of the tent
where my cold,
wet, icy rain pants
sat in the middle of a puddle.
And then I turned to my husband.
I glanced back at the
puddle, and back at Brew,
and just said, I
want your pants.
And my husband's
here, by the way.
I'm hoping you'll get to meet
him at the end of the talk.
But he is the sweetest guy.
And this is so Brew.
He did not bat an eye.
He did not disagree.
All he said during
this entire exchange
was, at least ask nicely.
He's like, at least say please.
So I did.
And then I kept
hiking in his pants.
And he packed up all our gear
and marched everything back
to the road crossing
on June 27 wearing
the "Grinch that Stole
Christmas" boxers.
I will never, never
forget that detail.
But I tell that
story not to talk
about my husband's underwear.
I tell that story, like so
many others that I could share,
because it clearly illustrates
that it's the support.
It's the support that's so
key in this type of endeavor.
If Brew had not assumed that
there had been bad weather,
if he had not hiked
in, if he had forgotten
the extra food or
the extra clothes,
I would not have been
able to keep going.
And I know people ask
all the time, why would
you want to set a record?
What's valuable about
that experience?
And for me, one thing
that was really important
was it took this trail that,
when I hiked as a 21 year old,
it had taught me all about
independence and self
sufficiency.
But now, eight years later, it's
teaching me all about teamwork.
It was teaching
me that sometimes
being able to ask for help is
far more important than being
independent.
And it was teaching me that
a strong team is always
going to be better than
a strong individual.
I'll be the first to admit
that there have been folks who
I consider to be much
better athletes who
have gone after this mark, and
they have not been successful.
Because they did not
have the level of support
that I received.
And there were a lot
of folks who helped us.
But Brew was the only one who
was with me from the beginning
all the way to the end.
And when I think
about our record,
I believe it has more
to do with his support
than with my athleticism.
And one of the reasons I
say that is because I know I
would have quit without him.
We got into Vermont.
And I still had my shin splints.
Now I had these weird side
effects from the hypothermia.
And because of that,
or on top of that,
I got really, really sick.
And that's not fun at
home, but it's especially
not fun on the trail.
The type of sick I had, I
wasn't even on the trail,
you know what I'm saying?
I was just running off
trail every few minutes,
grabbing striped maple
leaves, every-- I mean,
I was just miserable.
I was depleted, dehydrated.
And giving all that
I could, I still
couldn't go one mile per hour.
So for the first time
on any trail, I quit.
I quit.
100% in my mind, I was finished.
I was just going to get to
that next road crossing.
And when I made it there,
we were headed home.
So I finally arrived.
I walked out of
the woods crying.
And Brew was waiting for me.
So I told him how sick I was.
I told him how much I hurt.
And I told him that we were
finished with the trail.
And this was the man who gave
me the pants off his body.
I knew that he was going
to wrap me up in his arms,
tell me it was OK, and then
help get me to some place where
I could start to feel better.
So I looked at him
waiting for my embrace.
And he looked back at me, and
he basically said, suck it up.
Suck it up.
And there's this strange
phenomenon where every time I
tell this story, I literally get
a little angry at my husband.
I get a little bit mad.
But when it actually
happened, I was shocked.
I was caught
completely off guard.
Because he'll tell you--
we had talked about it.
This was my dream, not his.
He said if it were
up to him, we would
be having a normal vacation like
a normal family that summer.
Yet here we were in Vermont.
We were both uncomfortable.
It was hot.
It was humid.
There were black
flies everywhere.
I had never felt so
bad in my entire life.
And he wouldn't let me quit.
And here's what he said.
He said, if you
really want to quit,
if that's truly what
you want, that's fine.
But you just can't
quit right now.
He said, right now,
I think you feel
too bad to make a good decision.
So he said, I want you eat,
drink, take medicine, and then
just keep going
until tomorrow night.
And tomorrow night, if you want
to quit, I'll take you home.
And I left that road
crossing counting
the minutes and the miles
until I could officially stop.
But after several miles
passed, the medicine kicked in.
I was able to hold in
some food and some water.
And I felt a little better.
But when I felt a little
better, I still felt horrible.
And no part of me thought
that I could set the record.
Because I was doing the math.
I was there on day 12
averaging 38 miles a day.
And that meant every
day until the end,
for five straight
weeks, I was going
to have to hike an
average of 50 miles a day.
And I didn't think
that was possible.
But I realized that my ultimate
goal was not to set the record.
My ultimate goal was to
find my best on the trail.
We had talked about--
Brew is a planner.
So we're always talking
five or 10 years out.
And we knew we wanted our
next adventure to be a family.
I wanted to be a mom.
I wanted to have kids.
And I didn't want to have
to look back and just always
wonder, what did 100% look
like for me on the trail?
I wanted that answer.
And so I decided to keep going,
not necessarily for the record,
but to really find what
my best was on the trail.
And there was this huge
psychological shift
that occurred.
Because up until
that point, we had
fixated on numbers-- miles
per hour, miles per day,
where the previous record
setter was at any given point.
And in a lot of ways, it
was his hike, not ours.
But after Vermont,
the one thing we
said every day was,
just do your best.
And after 46 days
of doing our best
and leaving it all out on
the trail, we got to the end.
And when we arrived, we--
again, it was kind of a surprise
that we accomplished what
almost everyone thought
was impossible, and at times
what I thought was impossible.
But Brew never believed
that it was impossible.
We set the overall record,
and it was the first time
that a woman had surpassed
the mark of a man
on a long distance trail.
So it got some attention.
It got some praise.
It got some criticism.
And it got a lot of questions.
But here's what frustrated me.
No one was asking
the right questions.
No one really got
what it was all about.
And I'm winding down.
I know you all have
to get back to work.
But I want to take
a quick minute
and read a passage from my
new book, "Called Again," that
shares some of my
feelings and frustrations
right after we finished.
"After the journey
was over, Brew and I
immediately gave
multiple interviews
and answered copious
amounts of questions.
But no one seemed to be
asking the right questions.
No one once asked
what I had learned.
No one asked what the most
valuable part of the experience
had been.
Instead, everyone
focused on the numbers.
They wanted to talk about
how I hiked, and did not
run, 46.93 miles per day.
They asked what I had
to eat to consume over
6,000 calories per day.
And they asked if I was scared
to see 36 bears that summer.
Scared?
That was one of the
highlights of the trip.
Why didn't anyone
ask about the notions
of living in the present or
choosing something purposeful
and fulfilling over
something fun and easy?
What about the necessity
of asking other people
for help and of not succumbing
to the fear of failure,
or the idea that persistence
and consistency can
be more valuable than
speed and strength?
Why didn't they
ask about everyone
else who had helped us?
Wasn't it clear that this
was a group endeavor?
And what about Brew?
Why did no one realize that
the most miraculous part
of the summer was
not the record,
but how well my
husband had loved me
and served me along the way?"
I know that records
are misunderstood.
And I don't expect anyone
to leave here today and want
to go hike 47 miles.
But I hope you do you
leave here knowing
that when it comes
to the record,
it's about more
than the numbers.
And one thing I really
like about the record,
or the fastest known time, or
whatever you want to call it,
is that it's an amateur pursuit.
So you're doing it
for the love of it.
It's based on the honor system.
And I promise you, when you get
to the end, there's no trophy.
There's not even a free t-shirt.
There's nothing there.
But that doesn't mean
there isn't a reward.
And I've hiked in a
lot of different ways.
And that's one thing I love.
It doesn't matter if I'm
backpacking, or guiding a trip,
or going out for a day
hike with my daughter.
Every time I go outdoors,
there's a reward.
And that's my hope
for all of you.
I know you spend a
lot of time indoors
solving all the
world's problems.
But I hope that you take some
time to go outdoors and find
your reward as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I do have one last slide
show that includes pictures
from the Appalachian
Trail and our record.
But before I show that, I do
want to introduce my husband.
And if you don't
have to run off,
we'd love to take questions.
So we'll take about five or
six minutes of questions,
show the final slide show.
And then if you all are
interested in books,
Google has them available
at a discount for $10.
And we're happy to sign
those for you as well.
So let's start with questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Have
you done the-- I'm
going to butcher the
pronunciation-- Kalalau
Trail on Kauai in Hawaii?
JENNIFER DAVIS: Oh, is
that the one on the cliffs?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JENNIFER DAVIS: No,
we went to Hawaii.
Bu we had our then 16
month old daughter.
And we decided that was probably
not a family-friendly hike.
Yeah, stay away from the cliffs.
But we've heard about it.
And the hiking in
Hawaii was incredible.
And we would love to
go back and do more.
AUDIENCE: Where did
you hike in Hawaii?
Because I'm looking to
do some hiking there.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Sure, we were
on the Big Island, in Oahu.
And we hiked a lot.
BREW DAVIS: The
Big Island, there
is a place called Waipio
Valley that's west of Hilo.
And we went there, and we hiked
in Volcanoes National Park.
And then I guess on Oahu,
we did some shorter hikes
on the northwest
side of the island.
I can't remember the names.
But the ones that
would be recognizable,
we hiked around
Diamond Head and--
JENNIFER DAVIS: Manoa Falls.
BREW DAVIS:--Park, like
the close parks, yeah.
But there's--
JENNIFER DAVIS: We
hiked in Volcanoes.
Did you say that?
BREW DAVIS: Yeah, a lot
of good hiking in Hawaii.
It's pretty rugged.
Because it's just
muddy and slippery.
JENNIFER DAVIS:
And volcanic, too.
BREW DAVIS: Yeah, Manoa
Falls, that's right.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So before you go
out on these long hikes,
how do you prepare yourself?
What kind of training do you do?
JENNIFER DAVIS: Yeah, I
try to train physically.
The thing I think is
most helpful is climbing,
exercises with climbing.
Cycling is really good.
I like to wear a heavy
pack even when I train.
Because it helps
develop those muscles.
But anything physical
you can do is helpful.
I think it's important
to prepare emotionally.
Most people get off for
emotional reasons, not
physical reasons.
So be prepared to be away
from friends and family
and not take showers every day.
You have to kind of wrap
your head around that.
And then some people,
really they'll
just kind of get in
shape on the trail,
which you can also do that.
Because with work and
life, sometimes it's
hard to train or prepare.
And the most important
thing is to not
try to go too fast too soon,
or carry too much weight.
Because then you are more likely
to get injured, especially
if you haven't gotten ready.
AUDIENCE: What would
be your favorite hike
or your favorite place to go?
JENNIFER DAVIS: The Appalachian
Trail's asked the most.
It's given the most.
So it's my favorite.
But on top of that,
we loved Iceland.
We love Corsica.
There's 125 mile trail that
runs the length of Corsica.
I really liked Peru.
BREW DAVIS: We did
the Colorado Trail.
That's about a not quite
500 mile trail from Durango
to Denver.
And it's really
stunning, especially,
in the southern part
closest to Durango.
Tour de Mont Blanc,
did you mention that?
JENNIFER DAVIS: It was
in the photos, but--
BREW DAVIS: Tour de Mont
Blanc-- Italy, France,
and Switzerland,
that's a good one.
JENNIFER DAVIS: We'd
do them all again.
BREW DAVIS: Yeah.
JENNIFER DAVIS:
It's the problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I heard there was
a current PCT yo-yo attempt.
Would you be interested in
doing anything like that?
JENNIFER DAVIS: For me, the
Appalachian Trail record
was kind of the pinnacle of
these feats of endurance.
Partly because it's one
of the oldest marks.
The first person the yo-yo the
PCT, I think it was in 2006.
So it's a relatively new
thing, and a very hard thing
to accomplish.
Plus having a family--
doing it one way
is going to take, even if you
do it really fast, three months.
Doing it both ways, you're
gone for half of the year.
So now, my ultimate goal is
just to get people outdoors
and to experience the trail
in as many different ways as
possible.
And I'm fortunate that
everything lined up
and I got to try for the record.
But now we're section hikers,
meaning we do it in pieces.
And we have the guiding
company at home,
so we get people
outdoors that way.
And it's good.
We take our daughter outside.
It's definitely
a different pace.
It's not better.
It's not worse.
It's just all about seasons.
AUDIENCE: How much time did
you spend planning this hike?
BREW DAVIS: Very little.
We have a friend.
He knows the roads around the
Appalachian Trail really well.
Because he himself
has hiked it 17 times.
And he's also run
support for people.
And so before we started hiking,
we got the data book out.
And he would highlight
roads and say,
these are the roads that
you should focus on.
And I was teaching middle
school until the day
before we left for the trail.
And I think I also had sort of
banked knowledge of the trail
from when she did it in
2008, and I had already
done a support.
So for her, it was she knew
what she was going to do.
She was just going to hike.
For me, it was using
prior knowledge
and our friend's
knowledge to not get
turned around on the roads.
And I have a pretty good
sense of direction, too.
So I could rely on that.
So we didn't really plan
that part very much at all.
And we kind of
did it on the fly,
realized that we needed-- it
might be beneficial for Jen
to have some people
to hike with her
and give her some help that way.
JENNIFER DAVIS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: After all this
journey of life that you have,
how can Jennifer define herself?
JENNIFER DAVIS: Not by
hiking, surprisingly.
That's been key for me,
even going for the record,
is I thought, I
have to be fulfilled
whether we set this or not.
And the trail for me, that
first journey was so important.
Because it taught me
it's OK to just be me.
It is.
And the natural setting
helps you feel natural.
It helps you be yourself.
But being a hiker
doesn't define me.
I have a really wonderful
family and a strong faith.
And as long as I can, I'm going
to hike, and walk, and run.
But it's not the only thing.
So I think what frustrated
me about the questions
is everyone focused
on the end result.
No one asked about
what got us there.
And no one realized
that the things that
helped us do well
on the record could
be applied to anything in life.
We run a small company,
and the trail--
BREW DAVIS: It's going to be
like Google in a few years,
probably.
JENNIFER DAVIS: --was
my business school.
Yeah, it's going to
be just like Google.
BREW DAVIS: Right now,
it's kind of small.
JENNIFER DAVIS: But the
trail was my business school.
It taught me how to budget, and
work with all different types
of people, and not give up.
That's a huge thing
with a small business.
So I think it's got a lot
of really good lessons.
And it helps you figure
out your strengths
while you're out there.
Yeah, so I do think I want
to show the last slide show.
If you all have more questions,
we'll be hanging out.
You guys probably need to work.
But we'll be here.
And we can sign books.
And we want to thank you all,
and really thank Andrew too,
for making this possible.
So we'll conclude with this
last two minute slide show.
[MUSIC ALATHEA, "MY ROOTS GO
DEEPER"]